foreign
at the moment you have a scientific
establishment that has
to put it gently completely fumbled the
ball on covet
and
having fumbled the ball it has put a lot
of people in a very compromised position
people who aren't professionally
involved in science and some of them
aren't don't really have a deep
relationship with science at all they
trusted people who should be trustworthy
and it turned out those people are
terrible at what they represent
themselves at being excellent at
you and I are in an interesting
predicament because we have a
large number of places where we
challenged the official narrative and
now it turns out that we were correct
now as I said last week and I said many
times before we did not start out
correct
what happened was we started with
educated guesses hypotheses and got
more and more correct over time as we
built up a model how do you do that by
monitoring how predictive it is a
phenomena in the real world so your
model gets better and better it gets
more and more predictive maybe it
assumes less and less right that's the
process we went through
the problem is that creates a challenge
to all sorts of powerful forces going
forward because if you and I actually
succeeded in doing that right you know
thinking the experts not by using
anything fancy without their advantages
without any inside information without
the ability to commission experiments or
any of the things you might do in order
to really be at The Cutting Edge if we
were able to do it just by talking it
out
then something is really wrong that
should not be possible Right
find out think a certain number of
departments a field every now and again
but it shouldn't be possible to just
beat them across the board to the extent
that it is possible yes it's nice that
you and I have those capabilities yes we
studied a topic which puts us in a good
position to do it because it has a
generalist toolkit that comes along
because evolution is relevant to many of
the sub questions that are involved in
this but it is also evidence that
something is desperately wrong with the
institutional world right so my claim is
the institutional world has to find a an
excuse to
um
discount
what our viewers and listeners know
happened on Dark Horse it has to find
that now if it just had to find that and
it was alone in the universe fine it
would have a hard time
but it actually has a corresponding
group of people a large audience of
people who were taken in by the CDC by
the New York Times by all of the
official Outlets that were supposed to
be doing the work of curating the
information seeking new data right all
of the things that were supposed to work
to tell you what to think about covid
right the failure of that thing resulted
in a lot of people whose worst error was
just simply to trust that the experts
probably knew what the hell they were
talking about right those people got
burned
now some of them got injured
right some of them just got humiliated
and hopefully they haven't been injured
but the point is you've got a large
audience of people who got suckered by
something and are now trying to figure
out how to go back to living a normal
life and you've got a whole bunch of
people who screwed up who don't want to
be displaced over the fact that it is
now evident that they do not know what
they are doing and those two things are
now searching for a narrative in the
middle
and that narrative in the middle
is is kind of a negotiation right the
powerful people don't really want to be
Vindicated they can't be they got it
wrong what they want is to be slapped on
the wrist in a way that does not
threaten their position of power and the
people who got suckered would like to be
relieved of that sense of a oh there are
no experts that's a problem how am I to
live am I just going to wake up panicked
every morning right they would like to
be relieved of that they would like not
to feel
um so much like suckers they would like
to have somebody put into words the
mechanism by which they followed What
should have been true and reliable
instincts and ended up in danger right
and so my claim is that there is now a
struggle happening where
um influencers some of them humiliated
are now
seeking to
to provide a cell
where that sense of discomfort and the
powerful who do not want to be displaced
over their failure are interested in the
same thing and the Confluence of those
two things is a very powerful draw that
is going to pull people in if we're not
careful now
is it Petty to be focused on the fact
that this Viewpoint that they are
erecting is nonsense No in fact the
future depends on us not falling into
this trap and I will say at the
beginning of covid
what I said at least to those close to
me was that this was likely the best
opportunity that we were ever going to
get in our lifetime to reveal what was
taking place in the system the
dysfunction that you see inside of a
university right the failure of
Journalism to find obvious stories and
to report them these things are our
system coming apart our very lives
depend on it as we are now learning with
the various failures of Supply chains
and you know scarcity of various kinds
of foods our very life actually depends
on a system most of us do not understand
and that system is showing every sign of
coming apart so my sense is
we either take what we just learned from
the failures of covid
and use it to motivate us to figure out
how to repair the system well enough
that we can depend on it or we are going
to not only suffer the equivalent of
covid again in some new context maybe
having nothing to do with a pathogen
maybe it will be a different pathogen
who knows but that same collapse the
same inability of the experts to figure
out which way is up that thing is
putting us in danger and it will
continue to do so so we have to get in
the way and block that middle ground
Scramble for that Narrative of comfort
that makes people more comfortable now
and puts them in Jeopardy in the near
future yeah for sure and I think
um as you would predict from what you
just described that middle ground
scramble seems to be made up
almost entirely if not entirely of
people who are very educated
who
um
have viewed themselves as heterodox on
something in the past
and who
um reveal from things that they're
saying that either they can't or have
stopped being willing to engage in
logical arguments and
um and if you are not if if you are
going to take a everything is socially
constructed view of the world
you can't also claim to be on the right
side of history and so I was thinking
about this in the context of
um for a variety of reasons some of
which I don't know but some of which is
that I was in Portland and so ran into
more people this this last week
um we we've been hearing from
um a number of people who are
appreciative of what we're doing and I
was just thinking about of the people I
know like what who are these people in
the world what are they doing and this
is by no means a complete representation
but uh we have farmers and gardeners
artists and Artisans and makers pilots
and teachers Healthcare professionals
and people in the military people post
on nature and actual sustainability and
conservation not the thing that's
passing for sustainability and
conservation and so many
and if in so many circles now people who
don't actually like to go outside but
like to claim to be all about nature and
such
um people who don't like discomfort
we've got people who work in food co-ops
uh who understand stuff about you know
actual
actual food security who make ferments
and grow garlic and construct herbal
concoctions and get raw dairy from
people who who produce it and get it to
the people who think that they need it
or want it for for their own for their
own health
um musicians who speak truth to their
lyrics and their notes printmakers who
meld the wisdom of the past with amazing
images
there's more those every single word
that I just use there represents one or
more actual people whom we've heard from
in the last week or two and
every single one of them is doing
something real in the world with a real
manifestation in the physical world
social it's not entirely social and I
think that is going to be the you know
the predictive thing here like were you
paying attention to something that they
could not lie to you about early on or
throughout this pandemic at all so such
that at the point that what you knew to
be true because you experienced it with
your own senses and your own body at the
point that they made some claim that was
opposite you went no
not because you went into it needing to
disagree not because you went into it
needing to agree not because you were
faithful or cynical not because you're a
contrarian but because you went huh
that's not right
well now I'm going to be on a little bit
of an alert because that thing that I
was assured was true isn't true
oh there's another one
and oh boy and you know you quickly do
go into this space like oh wow I did not
know so many things were not true that I
was being told were true but the
assurances from the talking heads that
all you have to do is follow along and
you know I am the embodiment of science
over here and you know you just have to
do what this three-letter agency says
over here
people who actually have real physical
manifestations in the world because
they're flying planes or growing garlic
or making ferments or you know whatever
it is
we're much less likely I think
hypothesis to be fooled by this across
the board and it's the people who are
hyper-educated who don't spend time in
real physical space maybe you know maybe
build a fence like you know learn to lay
tile like something do something with
physical manifestation in the world
where you can see the results and not
negotiate your way into convincing
yourself that you were right all along
foreign
[Music]